as Clone Wars executive producer and
Mandalorian director Dave filoni
previously explained ahsoka's white
lightsabers are meant to show that she
is neither a Jedi nor a Sith revenge is
not the Jedi way
I am no Jedi in e.k Johnston's 2016
novel Ahsoka the author fills in the gap
between the Clone Wars and Rebels prior
to reappearing in Rebels Ahsoka defeats
an Inquisitor and takes his lightsaber
crystals because he is a Sith his
crystals were corrupted but Ahsoka heals
them and realigns them with Force this
turns them white a symbol not only of
their restored Purity but also of Ahsoka
leaving the order behind to fight for
good in her own way